-Happy Friday, everybody.
Today is Friday.
And that's usually when I
catch up on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox.
I return some e-mails,
of course,
and I write out some
thank-you notes on Fridays.
Yeah, I do it every --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I was just --
I was just wondering.
I'm a bit -- running
a bit behind today.
I thought,
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now during the show.
Is that okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you very much.
James, can I get some thank-you-
note-writing music, please?
[ Piano plays ]
Alright.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, good mood.
-Chewing gum?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Piano plays ]
Thank you,
Major League Baseball's
new 15-second pitch clock.
15 seconds might not
seem that long.
Or, as Stormy Daniels put it,
I beg to differ.
-Hey! Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Indicated.
Lick it.
-No.
[ Piano plays ]
Thank you, Florida Atlantic's
mascot Owlsley,
for looking like
the world's angriest Cinnabon.
[ Laughter ]
Mad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Growls ]
-He's mad but delicious.
Get a six-pack.
[ Piano plays ]
-Thank you, the people who keep
their ID and credit cards
in their phone case
for saying to the world,
"Eh, if I lose something,
it might as well be everything."
[ Laughter, applause ]
Take it all.
Just take it all!
-Take it all.
Well, can you call your wife?
-No, I can't even know if
I'm legally married anymore.
My wedding certificate's
in it, too.
[ Laughter ]
-The deed to my house.
[ Piano plays ]
-Thank you, glass,
for being the one thing
that's worth more stained.
-Oh, nice.
That's a thinker.
Yeah, that's a thinker.
-That's one of those --
You snap to that one.
-That's a snapper.
-Yeah. You don't clap.
You think about it,
then you go...
-Yeah, Daddio.
I grok. I grok.
-Yeah. Let me do it again.
I'll finish it up again.
Try again. Ready?
-Everybody snap.
[ Piano plays ]
-Thank you, glass,
for being the one thing
that's worth more stained.
[ Fingers snapping ]
[ Jazz music plays ]
-I can dig it.
Yeah, man.
He's a cool cat.
-Yeah.
-He's got his pen.
[ Music stops ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Piano plays ]
-Thank you, Cinderella,
for being the beautiful story
of a woman
who catfishes a prince.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-My shoe.
[ Piano plays ]
-Thank you, third time
guessing a computer password,
for letting me know the feeling
of what it's like
to defuse a bomb.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Yes!
We're in!
Cut the blue wire.
[ Piano plays ]
Thank you, sinks with hot
and cold faucets,
for making me feel
like a water deejay.
There you have it, everybody.
Those are my thank-you notes.